check out my brain it's otherwise the me
go go inside and the ring never you like
to hang anything what truster worchester
sauce rochester's well was Chester woof
woof woof ok ok Kevin hi everyone is
Nina I can request from shireen King she
requested burger recipe so I'm gonna
make a burger today so the ingredient
that you will need for burger of course
granny I bought this ground beef from
costco it's organic and it is 1.8
kilogram i'm going to use half of it and
then you will need one in half cup
mushrooms I chopped the mushroom last
night and then you will need 1 cup of
onion I chopped it up last night as well
you have to chop it with ice sighs you
will need 2 eggs you will need 2 TSP up
this cheese teaspoon of the soya sauce
and 1 teaspoon of salt and 1 teaspoon of
pepper and off of two cloves of garlic
I'm gonna chalk this one up
mushrooms I like to mix it first before
I have the egg and what's problem hahaha
you need help with something yes can you
pick it up x from your face let's take a
shelf it I'm saving the X up with my
planet because the slugs like eating my
my pepper leaves so I'm going to use the
next show so now I'm going to add some
pepper and sauce in the soil sucks God
truster sauce I said this month I came
in second two of two
what is that well that's my team we make
a raft last night with a black beans and
chicken this is all done so now we have
to make the patty so just just crack a
handful of me and then press it down and
try to make it to around a round shape
but the cheese is to remove this fun of
me it won't it won't work we need those
sheep
cuz this is a cheese cute does that look
like a cheater that's my birthday okay
that's it let me wash my hands then we
will cook i'm also going to make some
bacon so i can make cheeseburger bacon
cheeseburger
okay let it twice about two minutes
perfect about two minutes per side so
minute okay we don't want to flip too
much when you click too many times the
virtual will give to drive
so it will cook evenly
I could be we need it off to me you can
be brought what are you doing is that
your creek so you can put it on your
burger I'm going to cut out some Tamara
to just put a little bit of cheese we
don't have sliced cheese that just put a
little bit of cheese on top of the
patent
my mother's homemade ketchup
here you go sir II this is for you thank
you for requesting if you have any
requests please leave a comment below
I'll make it forever to travel and the
recipe you guys can use this
yeah how do you ever wash your hands on
my god sing us a Chinese sign see Kwang
ho ho bean siga ho bean well the car
wasn't doing buddy merry back